I'm Duncan Robinson with the Miami Heat
come shoot around with me favorite
current NBA player to watch Mo Vagner my
college teammate most memorable
three-pointer of your career game five
of the NBA Finals my second year in the
bubble if you could have any song play
after you hit a three-pointer what song
would you choose Blossom by her Kennedy
alltime dream NBA opponent those
Showtime Lakers also play against Coach
Pat Riley which defender in the league
makes you work the hardest Javon Carter
just the way that he plays and competes
kcp does a good job as well teammate
that you'd like to be stranded on a
desert island with I'll go with Klo I
don't know how useful he would be but he
would at least provide some comedic
relief who is your celebrity
doppelganger in college people used to
say I look like mmore people love to say
Jimmy Neutron and Sheen as well do you
agree with that I could see the Jimmy
Neutron I got a big head what would your
go-to horse shot be over the backboard
from behind the hoop let's see
it there it is